Welcome to problem set 6.
Let's take a look at the shortest tour problem.
Now let's say we wanted to use a randomized algorithm
to solve the shortest tour problem,
and how about we run it on an N-vertex graph.
Say we decided to run our randomized algorithm
a thousand times and we got the following results.
We got a tour length between a 1056 and 1537.
Along with that, we got the number of times
each of those results were found.
Now we also have a known factor to approximation algorithm,
and we found an approximation of 1236 with this.
Now what I'd like to know is given the above information,
and we will copy that information in the instructor comments below
so that you can look at it during the quiz,
which of these statements are true?
Does the shortest tour for the input graph have to have a length of 1056?
Is the random algorithm likely a factor 3 approximation algorithm?
Have we found a tour that is at most 1.71 times as long as the optimal one?
Or similarly, have we found one that is at most 1.43 times as long as the optimal one?
Check whichever of these you think are true.